get it since the movie takes place on
Mars they tinted the usual Disney logo
red well two can play at that game
Mars narration also you turned your
Disney logo Mars red then the first
spoken word of the movie is Mars so tell
me again why you felt the need to remove
of Mars from the original title McNulty
is an investigating Walter White for
drugs in this movie
how can you tell oh ship sarn't visible
until the camera pans over blue strings
of power I know when I get an amazing
gift that I don't understand from three
floating wise men my first instinct is
to try and blast them with it ah 1881
the year where only the black umbrella
was in fashion died following John
Carter somehow misses the one woman in
New York City wearing something bright
today and therefore mrs. John Carter
that's 50 cents unless you won special
delivery hey what if he want to change
name of sender Carter
Johnny Turner old-timey James Bond also
roll credits also Tim Riggins isn't
something something football dreamboat
reveled in this scene and we do believe
that this guy walked past Carter a
minute ago lost him in the sea of black
umbrellas and yet guessed correctly that
he'd go to this Telegraph place telegram
that can be read in one second is held
up for five seconds by a guy on a train
who obviously already read the very
simple message maybe he thought John
Carter included a cipher the income the
benefit my beloved nephew
Edgar Rice Burroughs wrote himself into
his own story and the words of Nicolas
Cage and adaptation it's kind of weird
isn't it this wild tale behaves thirteen
years ago
we are watching a movie about a guy
reading a story about a guy telling a
story obviously not they went right into
the bar and found him and he's at that
bar so much he ran up a tab over a
hundred dollars so no he's not hard to
find I'm gonna go ahead and send this
movie right now for putting Bryan
Cranston in it for like ten minutes
can we give this guy a whole movie for
once I paid in full character wears both
woman and man's wedding rone P plan
what's the plan if this guy wasn't brain
dead he's still horse okay so wait
didn't he have like this much of a head
start and he took the Colonel's horse
right so is the Colonel's horse way way
slower than the other horses and if
these horses are faster than his horse
why aren't they catching up to him now
oh I thought you didn't care I don't
cliche series of plot conveniences leads
John Carter to the cave he's always been
looking for and finds it just at a time
when one of these hologram dude shows up
Mars is convenient in that it has an
atmosphere with air to breathe and it's
not ridiculously cold and less gravity
so that John Carter can become Superman
did the hatching begin because he
started looking at them or is it just
super coincidental timing thankfully
this amulet that is clearly the conduit
to travel between Earth and Mars is
picked up by someone central to the
story within minutes of it being lost in
complete wilderness this guy just tried
to kill Carter but because Carter jump
really high immediately flipped his
goals upside down and fights for
Carter's life point is this guy really
likes jumping
don't ever show him Space Jam odds vodka
unfortunately for this story written way
back in 1917 the Star Wars prequels
happen and now everything I see reminds
me of those damn Star Wars prequels
Martians are dicks to their unborn
children and I'm okay with that
and I am NOT okay with that
to a world on the brink this chick isn't
something on my something in the scene
huh damn the best street leads his chips
less than useless
yeah but he's only got the ability to
shoot one thing in a concentrated beam
I'm sure you're not trying to attack
this guy one chip at a time because it
seems like a coordinated attack and take
this asshole down he will what nerve
center of the ninth ray is
inconveniently located at a distance
from the weapon itself giving shady
assholes walking behind a crowd of
people the ability to secretly destroy
it royal daughter is betrothed to
someone she doesn't love or want to
marry cliche I really can't decide on
whether I should send the father for
giving away his daughter before
consulting her or the daughter for
thinking she had a choice in the matter
this is a great time to transform back
into my evil self for no reason
adoption Reese he just being jumped a
second ago trying to get his port key
back all these people have already seen
him jump super far CGI Martian handle
arias Lee blocks John Carter's privates
as he's thrown into the goo Bowl didn't
a bunch of would-be parents claim these
kids during the child wrangling rodeo a
minute ago how do they decide whose baby
is whose
boy somebody's oh good they solved that
language barrier problem with some sort
of Gerber's horn liquid Wow and spotted
that instantly apparently John Carter
has the ability to kill a green Martian
with one hit but can't fight off all
these guys like cockroaches with the
same superhuman strength few times how
do you know from here that has anything
to do with her hester prynne
dam don't these guys ever use keys for
another the next defense would be last
this society judges worthiness based on
how much surface area skin you have on
your back a really fat guy could get
away with twice as many crimes seriously
Keys accidentally well-timed dramatic
attack coincides with John Carter's big
prisoner prove yourself seen that don't
duplicate fair fight seriously am I
missing something
it's a beam of light that he shoots in
one direction and multiple ships should
be able to surround and fire upon his
ship no problem she survives all this
okay so no gambit and Wolverines
girlfriend from x-men origins Wolverine
are in the same shot reminding us of
x-men origins Wolverine Carter loses his
sword but thankfully it literally lands
in the hands of the princess who is
already obviously his true love we've
been told that this blue yarn thing has
more power than just for killing so why
can't you use it to subdue or capture a
prisoner you can still bleed like sharks
ex machina and i cannot guarantee the
safety of your red girl okay first of
all in that red girl is racist second of
all how is she his red girl and how does
this Thark know that and the CGI got
super excited in the shot jump 23
percent of this movie is people
commanding John Carter to jump I did say
planet now let us wait until night Falls
to discuss this further some then Russ
despite calling the planets all
different names the people of Mars still
call the Sun Sun blessing mercury
this is either a sin for astronomy
lessons or from Mars to English lessons
I honestly don't care and girth John
Carter can jump hundreds of feet in the
air he's observed an entirely different
species and yet he still thinks he's on
earth that
she instantly knows he means the
medallion as opposed to the Thark more
their weapon in his hand or any of the
other objects that would have seemed
logical to a Mars girl that'll do in the
time of oceans they walked amongst this
Thark helpfully follows them and has the
very expositional information they seek
there's some so I'm not gonna ask
permission to pick you up and jump
straight up there with no warning just
when did this mistrust begin anyway
weren't they having a grand old time
fighting off sedan goons a minute ago
discount prince of persia
so why was there a mad scramble to chase
down and own babies earlier you must
hurry
I mean to release you but you were just
a fat no good fortune are you yep that
sound trips work yes you've been riding
around for days how do you not know that
already
even on Mars they play the pronoun game
also wait she was screaming about going
to helium would show Carter how worried
did their cause against a tango was but
helium aka her king dad had already sold
out and agreed to give her does the
dangus jet at but she thinks going back
to helium is the strategy for getting
out of marrying him Sam tan tardos mors
dotar Sojat tars tarkas I'd hate to
attend a college graduation on Mars she
is a princess Princess of Mars roll
credits only the book fans will get that
joke if you have a means to save others
would you not take any action possible
to make it sound like marrying the enemy
so it troops can spare the lives of all
your people take it all I have reached
these already damn didn't they go in the
wrong direction for days before turning
around this is longer than I thought why
are you even here why haven't you
already gotten your army to go stop them
if you knew they were headed that way
you haven't been doing jack since we
last saw you that's the second time
that's happened
it's like jump rape okay so he brought
the army here but why did he magically
show up to the canyon first then go find
the army then bring them back why didn't
it just appear near the army and then go
to this flashback during an action
sequence those two leads
what the hell does this even mean I
understand you weren't there to save
your wife and daughter from a fire but
how can you predict your future
punctuality for house fires or any other
calamities guy who couldn't handle a few
of those Starks a minute ago is suddenly
a one-man army when the movie needs all
you need to know about this fire is that
somehow his wife and daughter died but
not how the fire started or why he was
so damn Lee to save the guy who said
he'd never be late again is too late to
jump out of this pile of bodies he came
to me alone without an escort but I
decided to go with Plan Z and just trust
the guy who's been killing everyone all
this time with our two cities United
somehow this works despite the fact that
day job could easily buy more time to
set up her own ninth ray and not have to
marry this dickwad if he just ended him
right now when you have to do is marry
me this is like the most literal game of
marry kill ever these bad guy guards
fall for this terrific Lee stupid thing
you can get us did we not see you just
jumping from airplane to airplane but no
issues earlier this seems like a
challenge all of a sudden it's won by
the groom's mother I'm told what I mean
why are you wearing it then well they
built everything a trumping asshole
needs to avoid being seen in this room
didn't they earlier mark strong stopped
SAP then from shooting John because he
wanted him alive
but here it looks like he's perfectly
capable of controlling someone with this
blue web and they could have avoided
about an hour this movie who do not
exist indeed except for right now when
I'm telling a total stranger from
another planet all about it all so why
did he bother turning into an old lady
what's the point of that Fisher and she
came very close indeed
three it's a consequence now why is he
giving all this crucial information to
the audience I mean to John Carter when
the two moles meet and vows are
exchanged
she and anyone else with knowledge of
the ninth ray will be eliminated
oh good just enough time to foil the
plan we've been playing those games
before the birth of this planet literal
deus ex machina where his will have been
this whole time and are we supposed to
believe he's so fast he can surprise
attack a god will they even somehow knew
to bite down on the medallion to free
John even though it's never shown the
power to be able to hold someone
prisoner before you go ahead and stop
him don't you have the power
movie that either does or does not wish
to trade on Star Wars imagery devolves
into nothing but Star Wars imagery
regardless of its wishes oh come on
how did Sola know to be standing here
right now except in key scenes where he
might have been even more valuable but
hooray for the hero dog seconds after
placing Carter in this cell it's up now
we go time why did you even bring him to
the cell are they're just not latches on
these chains or do they have to cut
through them every time the chain budget
in the Thark clan must be insane
director had a conflict with a set
designer about enough spikes surrounding
the arena we are uniting because we call
our freaks we are strong because we
despise weakness said the guy I'm
missing a face horn who despite that
freakish weakness somehow became leader
don't you hate it when you're throwing
someone into an arena and you throw
yourself to god I hate that even if he
stabbed the white ape how do they not
all die from being underneath the white
eight when it falls dead
single person's chance somehow inspires
ground to join in cliche anti climactic
battle is anti-climactic how do stars
know what the salute sign is why is he
just returning a gesture you can't
possibly understand well if that means
I've your daughter or I'm covered in
nasty ass blue blood you saw the chick
shook his hand earlier right well he
wants to have its planetary cultural
misunderstanding cake and eat it too
Jesus this has been the longest day ever
giving the movie the benefit of the
doubt and I don't John maybe wakes up
the next day after he slaughtered all
these worthless guys but then there's
the escape the jumping the meeting with
the princess getting controlled by Mark
Strong watching some of the wedding
ceremony
John asking questions that don't get
answered another escape getting captured
again and we assume taken a long way
back to where the Tharks live thrown
into a dungeon fighting the white Apes
killing Thao and then back on the road
to stop the wedding graduates taught
lots of whatever's hit an unguarded
thing and the Tharks are home free how
could Carter predicted that head
slapping asshole
this cultures weddings I'm the bride and
groom carry a literal chain on route to
the marriage ceremony yeah but aren't
you given some sort of instructions
about possible aircraft flying through
during the wedding and are you the only
two people concerned with this thing Sam
decides to swing his sword at the water
thing rather than deja even though he
has a clear and easy stabbing Lane what
is this asshole waiting for remember
when you were begging his ass to fight
for your side in the war because he was
such an awesome warrior kind of doesn't
drive with this cute scene here whatever
I gave up so long ago I still think
we're in America he's afraid to see just
kill him already funny but since we've
been told over and over again that
Tharks don't fly the fact that they were
able to fly it perfectly into this
Cathedral is some bullshit John uses
this advantage to stab Sam in the knee
rather than lopping his fool head off
Shang immediately kills sab with the
blue matrix but somehow has to go
through a long slow ordeal with John so
that deja can save the day is there an
advantage for turning into deja here I
mean two hot chicks is better than one I
suppose but you know I mean
strategically here's another villain
talking instead of killing jack
see you have seen German oh wait metal
or metal or metal metal John proposes
marriage after only knowing this woman
for two days also whoa taking off your
dead wife's wedding ring to give it to
the Mars girl you love now that is a
romantic party foul and then they got
married immediately
thank goodness Earth people in March
based heliumites have private parts that
allow for romantic sexual marriage yep
this can't possibly come in handy ever
again Junko Mars sounds much then why
did you name the movie just John Carter
like a fool I had thrown away my
medallion narration and even worse not
even the same dude that narrated in the
opening of this film for if my body dies
on earth will my copy dies on Mars yeah
but what's happening with your copy on
Mars do they see your lifeless body at
the castle and put you in storage or
something bad guys continue to attack in
a way that is slow and makes no sense
it's often derived from the first
simulates the drug that simulates death
cliche Wow they change the title that
late that they didn't even have time to
remove this whoever in the marketing
department decided at the last minute to
whitewash Mars from the movies title
that guy is an idiot you were jumping
fantastic push push but one man bursts
his founds to fight for justice with his
companions Lamar and Princess Ariel
so perhaps together the Mokhtar help me
obi-wan Kenobi
Tenace blue is blue oh okay Klaatu
Barada